first let's take a look at the latest
scenes from kabul barbed wire has now
been put up outside the walls of kabul
airport but it hasn't stopped people
climbing the walls to try to get into
the airport and onto the runway earlier
people rushed onto the tarmac and tried
to climb onto moving military aircraft
and there are unconfirmed reports
that at least seven people died at the
airport
well people were also seen trying to
board commercial flights they have since
been suspended as well
[Music]
well us troops trying to secure the
airport fired shots into the air to try
to prevent hundreds of people running
onto the runways one official described
the crowd as out of control
meanwhile away from the airport on the
streets of kabul the taliban have set up
security checkpoints they're halting
traffic and checking inside cars
well let's go live to kabul and talk to
our chief correspondent stuart ramsey
there stuart first of all uh tell us
more about some those scenes we've been
witnessing today at the airport
yeah absolute chaos isn't it and it's
obviously resulted in the suspension of
this whole airlift and it's going to put
it back because commercial flights can't
come in either even if if they were able
to get some control we've heard uh
shooting uh pretty much throughout today
and helicopter gunships above us the
shooting we understand was actually uh
afghan forces trying to shoot over the
heads of people to get them to go away
from the gates of the airport we saw the
taliban there as well
trying to push people away shooting one
person we saw being shot at as after
they had got through uh the barricades
and of course those incredible pictures
are on the runway and of people uh
jumping onto planes and and and so
basically while they're still moving
incredible scenes and absolutely
incredible chaos now obviously something
had to be done so as you said they've
put over the wire and they're trying to
secure
or better secure the entire uh runway
but people of course are going it is a
huge complex and people will be
attempting to get over the wall
surrounded by a very high wall uh all
the time we suspect which is why there's
patrols going around you can probably
hear the shooting then that's that's the
same thing as they see people
approaching then they they fire uh in
the air so that suspension happened um
we're not certain when it's likely to
resume uh they'll have to presumably be
certain that they can control uh the
people this time because it has been
pretty awful um we've we've been hearing
from people saying who had tickets even
though those commercial flights didn't
happen but they had tickets they were
literally just pushed um out of the way
by people who had no paperwork uh of any
description i have heard reports that
one of the reasons for this at one of
another an airline i'm not sure which
one it was actually did just pretty much
let anyone on from the runway and that's
what's caused this because it's spread
like wildfire that if you can get
through the barricades then you can
get onto the
runway and then onto the onto the plane
of course the americans are now totally
in control of the whole airport or at
least nominally they are including the
air traffic control section but it was
this sort of a breakdown of law and
order outside and inside that's caused
such a delay now for the removal of
people and i think one thing that people
are beginning to come to to
understand and that includes the afghans
who have permission to travel to the
various countries they've been working
for is that if there's growing pressure
on this airlift then there'll be
priorities made and those priorities are
likely to take out the foreign nationals
and the afghans could easily be left
behind and for many of them they fear
that that is a death sentence and
while the country's
involved britain the united states but
others as well
are sorrowful about that
ultimately they will prioritize their
own nationals and
there could be some dreadful stories if
these people have to return to their
homes and the taliban start looking for
them which most people here are
convinced they're going to do and i
would just say on that point the we've
been uh interviewing uh the taliban
today number of fighters and they've
been saying to us that we're not going
to go after anyone that there is an
amnesty and that people can carry on uh
their lives as normal i think that's
what the everyone here is waiting to see
and the international community is
waiting to see is where the taliban
really have changed their ways i'll be
honest with you i'm somewhat skeptical
yeah because we're getting uh these
reports well we heard it from the un
secretary general of uh chilling human
rights abuses taking place in
afghanistan are you hearing anything
about what's going on on the streets
away from the airport
yeah well just quickly on that note uh
uh dermot over the last days that we've
been here i have seen a lot of videos
that we can't broadcast but it's dead
people basically who have been murdered
and laid out by the taliban and those
were either militia or people they
identified as having worked for either
foreign governments
or the afghan army and we've seen this
in towns and villages not so much in the
in the major cities now as it stands
today in kabul things are nowhere near
back to normal but as the day has
progressed more and more people have
come out onto the streets there's more
traffic uh you know bear in mind it was
absolutely deserted only a day or so ago
and um
shops have been opening but it is
absolutely awash with taliban fighters
they're everywhere um interestingly
excuse me interestingly they were
prepared to pose uh for our cameras and
give interviews now that i is incredible
i've never seen a change like that i
never thought i would see that uh where
they were quite happy to appear on
television you remember tv was banned uh
over 20 years ago and so um they they
are saying and bringing this this uh
position
that uh their leadership have tried to
sell to the international community that
it is a new look reformed taliban and
that while they will be strict they do
want it to be a more inclusive society
huge skepticism here by many people
certainly in the international community
i think one of the reasons they want to
do this obviously it is 20 years further
on and things have changed even for the
taliban but also they want to not just
have the support of say three countries
which i'm pretty certain it was when
they last had a government here but they
would actually like their neighbors for
example pakistan and russia example for
example to be supportive of them and on
board and to recognize them and for
other countries as well and you're only
going to do that if you do behave uh
responsibly and don't just start acting
like you're coming from the middle ages
for example and
that might be their plan the only thing
i would say to that is that might be
fine for the enlightened elite of the
taliban if you like the people who have
been involved in the negotiations
in qatar but for some of the
fighters um
they're very very conservative and they
have always ruled the areas uh
particularly in the provinces and the
regions which they've held for really
quite a long time never really lost it
to the coalition they've always had this
really hard core position
girls should stay at home they don't get
educated off the age of 11
and so on um whether they'll go down
that route we don't know will they
insist on burkas again most people seem
to think maybe not this time but we we
just don't know and so you have these
two things to where we have what is
going to happen in the future
the politics and the society all the
various issues but right now we've got
chaos at the airport this huge airlift
and it is a volatile situation it's
still very dangerous here
stuart ramsey live in kabul thank you